in an answer or other question I don't
know how other shows do it and how you
know how much of sort of their duty of
care they fulfill I think made in truck
in the early days I think it was when no
one really knew what it was gonna be
right and no one and no one really knew
how big these shows were going to get
because it was kind of well at the same
time as TOWIE we were kind of sort of
the first shows like that which which
which kind of catapulted all of us into
sudden I don't know well I guess Fame or
whatever and you know we were we were
recognized you know everywhere we went
but and and and certainly some people
were stable enough to deal with that and
certain other people didn't you know
weren't and and I you know it's all a
lot of people kind of break down from
that from the from the from the show and
the sort of whole fallout from it so
that's really interesting so what tell
us a little bit about that because I
think most ordinary people will always
wonder like this guy's a millionaire
he's getting a lot he's famous she's got
you know hot women walking up to him on
the street blah blah blah yeah sorry let
me just finish this question right like
what is the the thing that drives people
crazy or that makes people go off the
rails when that happens well okay so I
think the nature of these shows
presenting themselves and the and the
actual end product as reality you know
them dealing with the cast members
and saying that all has to be real you
you lead certain people to almost become
caricatures of themselves and they do it
and when their lives become so deeply
intertwined with what's going on
on-screen and and and the sort of the
chaos and and and drama that comes with
that they kind of lose track of what is
real and what isn't and who they really
are so they lose self-awareness and and
it's quite it's it's been quite
interesting obviously a lot of the cast
well pretty much all of the cast I knew
before you know from from childhood
right from from school and stuff like
that and and so it was it was it was
interesting to see some people and how
how it affected them you know I'm not
gonna select name OCR just off camera
because right now we have got especially
young people this obsession of fame fame
sake if you ask you know if you form a
teacher you are sees kids what they want
to be when they go out want to be famous
well nobody want to be famous was a an
amazing football no it's famous for and
it's it's it's amazing because it's sort
of fed right into the hands of big tech
and you know wanting to kind of share
their entire lives with the algorithm
which is eventually going to kind of
know everything about you and it's going
to be able to make better decisions for
you and for your life then you will
write it's gonna be able to say well
actually don't go for this car because
you know you know you're much more
compatible and it'll be right and
getting that way and but I do think that
you know Fame is an unnatural phenomenon
right you know you you would never in
nature right if when we were sort of
living our sort of tribal
hunter-gatherer lives be able to become
hugely famous right there was no there
was no vehicle before the printing press
or or you know
obviously there were the
sort of eventually those kinds of kings
and and and royalty and stuff like that
but thing and so I think psychologically
we don't really know how to deal with it
and it's an it's almost a excites people
and and and the idea of it
I think definitely it's it's it goes
hand in hand this sort of desire for
fame and these sort of treating famous
people like they are almost kinds of you
know demigods right like people do
people treat them like that they're
bigger and more important than just the
average goings on the street
[Music]